I think that freedom everywhere,
anywhere, is love.
Letting yourself be loved,
which is always risky.
And loving, which is
maybe even riskier.
I've been an monk here
at Pluscarden for 47 years.
Prayer I suppose is the
greatest freedom of all,
because
it's a relationship,
it's a gift of God,
it's very mysterious I think.
It's a gift and you just
accept what comes.
Silence is an enabling thing.
It frees you for
listening, for availability,
for avoiding imposing yourself.
How often in speech
are we trying to do someone down
or demonstrate our superiority
or all of that.
So, silence frees you
from those things.
Most monks do all sorts of things.
So you take your turn washing up,
peeling the spuds, cooking the lunch,
driving the car.
Many little jobs.
Just like a family.
Habere est Haberi,
which means, "What you possess,
possesses you."
The less you've got,
the more freedom you have.
And that’s
a freedom which is quite hard
to acquire in some ways
because letting go of things
is detachment.
It's difficult but it's essential
for freedom
because as our lives go on,
you have to let go of things.
Maybe your memory, maybe your sight,
maybe your hearing, maybe mobility.
You've got to let them go.
Because one day,
you have to let go of your life -
the ultimate impoverishment.
But that’s the only way to get
to the freedom of eternal life.
It will be tough at times,
everybody's life is tough at times.
But as they say, the retirement
benefits are out of this world.